the minneapolis police department has
been criticized many times for alleged
racial bias and misconduct by its
officers
it was investigated by the justice
department in 2015
the year that loretta lynch became
president obama's attorney general
now during her term she investigated
other police-related deaths including
eric garner here in new york and freddie
gray in baltimore
loretta lynch joins us now from new york
city
it's very good to see you madam attorney
general i want to start with this
i want to know what did you think what
did you think when you saw the tape
of of of the death of george floyd right
before eyes
and what did you see when you looked at
officer schauvin to me those are two
different questions
well certainly the first thing i thought
when i saw it was that this
was an abject failure of police culture
this was a uniformed law enforcement
officer
uh acting with an attitude of not just
nonchalance
but impunity and snuffing out the life
of an american citizen not only in broad
daylight but in front of other
americans seemingly protected by other
officers
that was the first thing that i saw when
i thought about it
uh when i could get over the heartbreak
of seeing it and focus on it
it was just it was to think that this
was ultimately
a picture of not just one officer going
off the deep end but also
a failure of culture a failure of
accountability
and i think that that is what everyone
else has seen as well
that attitude of not just impunity but
nonchalance
this is the straw that has broken
america's back when they consider
this case out of all the other examples
of police misconduct that we've seen
i think for a lot of people just seeing
the officer with his hands in his pocket
which just says the ultimate of i'm very
comfortable here
let's talk about the other three
officers that were on the scene
none of them intervened to say that's
enough please stop
do you think or are you surprised that
the three others have not been charged
at this time
well i'm not surprised that they were
all terminated i do think that those
officers showed
an abject failure to manage the
situation to recognize
that one of their own had turned against
the code that they all swore to uphold
and was actually harming someone in
front of their very eyes
i do think that those charges are going
to be under consideration my
understanding is now
the state attorney general is involved
as well so i know they're going to look
at everything
i would not be surprised to see charges
against those officers also
this really also deals with the issue
that we hear so many times
about whether or not this is a systemic
problem
or just the actions of a few bad
officers
it's clearly more than just that because
if you have a few bad officers you have
to ask yourself the question of
who hired them who trained them who
promoted them
and not only that who's protecting them
here
in the video of mr floyd losing his life
we saw an officer
not just snuffing out a citizen's life
but other officers
standing by and preventing the crowd
from intervening
listening to the crowd reacting telling
the crowd to get back
essentially saying your voice doesn't
matter here
that's what people heard and saw that's
what they're reacting to
what can you tell us about police
culture and what needs to change
i know you've done a lot of work in that
area
yes and and the the the added tragedy to
all of the scale
is that we know what to do we have seen
police departments turn things around
we have seen police departments become
better become accountable to the
community
become partners to the community we've
seen them do the hard work
that this requires and it is hard work
first thing that requires gail
is the courage to face this issue that
this is a problem
that so many citizens in this country
mostly minority but not limited to the
black community at this point in time
have lost faith in law enforcement and
when that happens
when people feel that there's no one for
them to turn to
no one there to protect them those
people are already living
in a desert of anarchy and it's law
enforcement's responsibility to reach
out
and bridge that divide it takes courage
to face the fact
that his that history has gotten us to
this point that years and generations of
police actions
have tainted law enforcement to the
point where this
is the image of policing in america you
know even the good officers are you
optimistic at this point by this officer
of what he did
you know unrealistic are you optimistic
and realistic that things could change
i'm realistic because and somewhat
optimistic only because i've seen it
change
i've seen police departments turn around
i've seen them sit down with the
community
and have those hard discussions about
the pain that they have caused
i've seen them listen to what the
community has to say and i've seen them
literally turn things around
and become better and stronger for it
but it requires a strength of will
it requires a commitment to continue
those actions
long after the smoke has died down from
this weekend
and long after people have gone back to
their homes exhausted from this most
recent round
of misconduct and protest and everything
that goes with it
it requires hard hard work and it also
requires scale
it also requires law enforcement
speaking out and taking responsibility
for this
which we are now seeing and i'm glad to
see that
yeah i am i'm not looking for a
comparison here between president obama
and president trump they are very two
different leaders
but i'm wondering your thoughts about
what you're seeing about how he is
handling this situation briefly if you
could
well look i think that what we look for
in our leaders and what we hope for in
our leaders particularly
our president is to be heard we want
them to hear
us we want them to hear our pain we want
them to lead the entire country
we want them to look at us even if our
experience is not their experience
we want to see empathy and an ability to
connect
an ability to say even if i'm not
experiencing what you're experiencing
i do see the pain that this is causing
and we as a country will come together
and work to heal that's what we look to
see
and i leave it to people to decide where
that message is coming from at this
point in time
all right loretta lynch thank you very
much for your time this morning